first case is Fisher vers University of
Texas at Austin if this case sounds
familiar that's because you've heard
about it before a few years ago the
court heard oral arguments in Fisher and
then a few months later kicked the case
back down to the lower courts in a very
anticlimactic decision well the
University of won once again in lower
courts and now the decision is back
before the Supreme Court so the issue
here is does the Fourteenth Amendments
Equal Protection Clause prevent the use
of race by the University of Texas in
Austin in its undergraduate admissions
program the University says it's using
race in a holistic manner in an attempt
to create equal critical mass of
underrepresented minorities on campus
Abigail Fisher the young woman
challenging this provision argues that
the university's actions violate her
rights under the Fourteenth Amendment
but the Supreme Court is gonna do is
going to say a is the school's use of
race narrowly tailored to achieve a
compelling government interest and also
is the school's use of race a compelling
government interest in and of itself
judging by the current makeup of the
court and the fact that the court has
agreed to hear this case again and
permit of action in public universities
undergraduate admissions is in trouble
the second big case I'm watching is
called Friedrich versus California
Teachers Association this is a challenge
to the legal privileges enjoyed by
public sector unions specifically
teachers unions in California the case
is even more important than that because
at issue is the survival of a very
important Supreme Court precedent known
as Abood coming out of Michigan in 1977
and what a bhoot said was that teachers
unions could either require membership
or require non-members public school
teachers to pay a fee which is the
equivalent of union membership what's
going on in this case is a school
teacher in California is objecting to
this regime arguing that by being
compelled to pay the equivalent of union
dues she's being forced to subsidize
political speech as a condition of
employment political speech that she
disagrees with the third case I'm
watching is called Lewis versus United
States now this case may not be in
everyone's radar but it's also very
important especially for those of us
concerned with property rights and civil
asset forfeiture the central issue in
the case is the Sixth Amendment right to
an attorney
prosecutors would like to freeze all of
the assets of a woman accused of
operating complicated Medicare fraud
scheme down in Florida this woman Miss
Lewis would like to use those
good assets to pay for an attorney as is
her right under the Sixth Amendment the
government however has moved
successfully to freeze all of her assets
before trial and would then later on in
the process would like to seize those
assets under asset forfeiture laws so
this is a case that poses important
questions about the reach of the sixth
amendment as well as the reach of
federal prosecutorial power and what
sort of limits the sixth amendment may
place upon that power